hey Sean how are your good right so what
make you a global citizen were you
taking a stand on things that I truly
believe in and and feel passionate about
you know and like the biggest thing I'm
here to do today is just to inform
people that there's ways they can get
involved and the ways are much simpler
than they may even know but yeah if you
were a world leader I would say honestly
the bigot makes you a global citizen is
listening and actually paying attention
a lot of people just live every day kind
of ignoring what's going on in the world
because their life may be a little bit
more blissful pay attention and listen
and learn because your empathy kicks in
very fast when you start to actually
understand what's going on in the earth
so are you nervous to perform tonight
I'm not I'm thrilled I'm excited there's
no reason to be nervous and it should be
good yeah yeah exactly yeah
congratulations on the YouTube thank you
thank you tell me about
a person I was I was so blown away Casey
nice that is an incredible director and
who did a great job and I hope the fans
love it I think they do and were you
surprised when your troop when they got
out there your tweet your oh no I wasn't
surprised and it's not that big of a
deal oh thanks so much thank you
you